meine These die ich mitgebracht habe ist
tatsächlich die dass wir jetzt einen
guten Schritt haben ja bei cut aber
schon im Juni gesagt dass jede
Kilowattstunde zählt und wenn jede
Kilowattstunde zählt eben auch jede
Kilowattstunde unabhängig davon wo sie
erzeugt wurde und wie sie erzeugt wurde
dazu gehört ganz eindeutig auch die
Kernkraft in Deutschland weiter zu
betreiben über einige Monate im nächsten
Jahr hinaus weil das die voraussetzung
ist dafür dass Energie nicht noch
zusätzlich verknappt wird und genau das
Preissignal negativ weitergewendet wird
wie es im Moment gesendet wir haben die
Situation dass die Preise enorm steigen
dass zahlreiche Unternehmen in
Deutschland vor der Situation stehen
Neuverträge machen zu müssen ab Januar
im Moment angesichts der Verteuerung
auch bei Strom denn wir haben eine
stromkrise auch das wurde viel zu lange
auch negiert auch von Teilen der der
Grünen in dem Teil negiert wie es falsch
war und wie sich jetzt herausstellt dass
Unternehmen wirklich massiv unter
Bedrängnis geraten weil die
Kostensteigerung im Prinzip nicht
leistbar sind deshalb müssen die
Energieversorgung ausgedehnt werden die
jedes Kilowatt muss bereitgestellt
werden aus ausgas aber natürlich auch
aus der Kernkraft ich bin ja ganz bei
Hersteller der dann auch sagt wir müssen
auch darüber nachdenken wo haben wir
eigene vorkommen die wir vielleicht auch
für die Zukunft noch nutzen können da
sind wir beide nicht weit auseinander
aber wir müssen jetzt die richtigen
Entscheidungen endlich in die Wege
leiten ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir
das schon vor der Sommerpause auf den
Weg gebracht hätten und ganz ehrlich
zwei Kraftwerke von drei reichen nicht
wir sind im Wahlkampf in Niedersachsen
im Moment darf die Partei nicht vor dem
Land stehen und deshalb bin ich auch
dafür dass wir tatsächlich jetzt die
Kraftwerke weiter betreiben die noch am
Netz sind sie kommen direkt noch einen
Schritt weiter wie realistisch
die Firmen die die Verträge abschließen
im Januar die Preise werden ja definiert
auf den erwarteten Preisen das ist
Feinde das heißt es wird immer so getan
es nützt uns nicht Tracking dauert sechs
Monate wenn wir anfangen
führt zu einem fallenden Preis die
Ankündigung 6 Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen führt zu einem
massiv fallen den Preis darüber das ist
ganz entscheidend ist für die
Unternehmen die richtigen Preise
entscheidend und deshalb nochmal und
wenn er im Juni hat er das gesagt bin in
Kilowattstunden wurde sie nachgeschaut
haben
innerhalb von sechs Monaten hättet ihr
eigenes tracking-gast die ganze Zeit
Produktion es wurde die erste Gastwirte
strömen es gibt die technologiens ist
ready go to go die Maschinen sind
greifbar am Markt muss aber Prinzip die
Maschinen kaufen hinstellen es dauert
ungefähr vier bis sechs Monate man muss
natürlich genauso schnell genehmigen wie
man die Energie Termin ist mit genehmigt
hat aber ich will jetzt gar nicht darauf
jetzt vorbei die Sache ist die wir sind
im Wirtschaftskrieg und der
Wirtschaftskrieg wenn wir so agieren ja
das geht überhaupt nicht wir können
nicht führen wenn jeder Flughafen gebaut
haben wir müssen die Wirtschaftskrieg
führen die mal Wirtschaftskrieg führt ja
hätte Churchill so gegen uns gekämpft
wäre als ganz anders ausgegangen in der
Geschichte das heißt wir müssen ganz
ganz radikal vorgehen und das vermisse
ich einfach und Diskussion ist einfach
lächerlich ja die Diskussion überführen
sind lächerlich und im Juni unsere das
ist alles viel zu spät oder das Problem
der ganze Sache ist
wenn die Preise nur auf dem fünffachen
Niveau bleiben
das trifft ja als Bürger alle Zuschauer
trifft das ist trifft die Firmen und die
Firmen sind nicht wettbewerbsfähig das
geht wir haben ein Faktor so USA von 1
zu zählen und das wäre aber eine Rolle
Energie ist Leben und wenn wir die ohne
günstige Energie ist der Wohlstand
hinüber und damit ist alles hinüber und
übrigens auch alle unsere Bemühungen zum
Klimaschutz kann man da vergessen weil
dann können wir sie uns nämlich nicht
mehr leisten erstellt hat ja recht
Energie ist der dreh- und Angelpunkt für
unsere Wirtschaft das ist doch Kapital
und das ist für jede Wirtschaft ich gebe
Ihnen Recht das ist doch ganz klar aber
sie tun so als hätten wir erst hohe
Energiepreise seit dem Krieg wir hatten
auch schon vorher relativ hohe
Energiepreise im europäischen im
weltweiten Vergleich und unsere
Unternehmen waren da auch schon in der
Lage dazu sich dem Wettbewerb zu stellen
das darf deshalb auch eine zu negativ
gesehen werden und wir müssen jetzt auch
dafür sorgen ah das Energie zur
Verfügung steht dazu gehört dann auch
einfach dass man in einer Krise mitten
in einer Krise nicht noch bestehende
Kapazität
anderes würde das würde das bedeuten
aber gerade LNG und das Verfahren für LG
und die Schnelligkeit mit der diese
Gesetzgebung in Gang gebracht werden
konnte zeigt doch auch was möglich ist
das zeigt doch auch was möglich ist in
unserem Land und das ist das was mich
antreibt nämlich jetzt auch zu
ermöglichen was geht um durch diese
Krise durchzukommen und auch für die
Zukunft den Baustein dafür zu legen dass
wir vielleicht dann tatsächlich
werden wir müssen uns hier jetzt mal
ganz ehrlich machen die Unternehmer in
diesem Land fühlen sich ja gerade von
der FDP eher verlassen als dass man das
Gefühl hat das Kampfmodus ist und Sie
haben gerade gesagt wir sollten das
jetzt alles nicht zu negativ sehen
vorher waren die Energiepreise auch ich
sage immer was sie haben eben gesagt man
wird sehen ab 1 Januar die Verträge
schon jetzt können mittelständische
Unternehmen in diesem Land keine
Verträge mehr ab 1 Januar 2023 mit E.ON
und Co abschließen die müssen jetzt
betteln gehen bei den Stadtwerken
betteln gehen bei den Grundversorgern
das heißt wenn ich jetzt Unternehmer
wäre und sie sitzen sehen würde die
sagen wir müssen da jetzt auch die
Krisensituation ist noch nicht so ganz
da würde ich ja ausrasten vor dem
Fernseher
Unternehmer sagen also wenn ich jetzt
Unternehmer aber ich würde ausrasten
wenn sie sagen was die ja auch aus und
ich verstehe das ja auch und die
Situation wir haben ich habe bin ich
Wirtschaftsminister in diesem Land wir
können nur alles tun um Energie auch an
den Markt zu bringen um die Preise zu
senken Marktsignale zu senden die Sie
gerade gesagt haben dazu gehört
tatsächlich mehr als als zu reden das
hat so lange gedauert das ist ja ohne
Zweifel aber jetzt dann auch wirklich
dahin zu gehen und zu sagen ja wir
machen das mit der Kernkraft wir
betreiben die weiter wir nehmen die
Kohle jetzt wirklich ans Netz und reden
nur darüber dass sie ans Netz gehen soll
wir schaffen auch die regulatorischen
Voraussetzungen dafür dass die
Kohlekraftwerke tatsächlich auch
hochgefahren und in Betrieb werden
können was ja was ja auch nicht
stattgefunden hat oder Sommer aus vielen
Gründen die Kohle wurde nicht dahin
transportiert jetzt haben wir Probleme
mit der ammoniakversorgung was
tatsächlich auch am Schornstein eine
Rolle spielt es gibt viele viele Hürden
die im Moment zu überwinden sind und die
auch regulatorisch zu lösen sind und ich
kann Ihnen nur sagen als Mitglied einer
Fraktion die die Regierung trägt tun wir
Tag und Nacht alles dafür um zu
Jugendlichen was geht und das würde ich
mir tatsächlich auch leider Gottes
halt nicht ausreichend gemacht und wie
die höchsten Energiepreise zu sagen
deshalb ist es gut wir haben schon aber
wir haben schon mit den hohen
Energiepreisen schon eine Abwanderung
Industrie gehabt aber sie haben Recht
die Industrie hat sie nach Möglichkeit
die sich anpassen konnte sie angepasst
das Problem an der ganzen Sache ist da
die Preissteigerung von über 15 Jahre
statt genau
paar Wochen paar Monate statt und da
muss man ganz anders handeln deshalb
brauchen wir auch ein gaspreisdeckel
damit man muss auch das finanziert
werden und witzigerweise wir könnten
unseren gaspreisdeckel problemlos
finanzieren das können sie mal ihrem
Freund Herrn Winter sagen indem er
Fracking fördern und hinter die Einnahme
von Tracking in Deutschland dazu nutzen
um damit die Rechnung zu bezahlen die
wir jetzt für Subvention von Gas